demandez à thomas mann les plastiscines
moi je pense qu'une pièce de théâtre
d'été qui a une chemise à fleury c'est
un mauvais signe le brassard est l'une
des têtes d'affiché de la pièce garçon
présenté dans plusieurs villes
québécoises cet été on veut que les gens
repartent avec un sourire un
divertissement mais la pièce ou s'ils
proposent carrément une intrigue
intéressante puis on n'est pas juste
dans le gros rires gras ou fait rire à
tout prix tout en reprenant les codes
qui ont fait le succès des théâtres des
tic
la troupe de garçons se présenter une
pièce plus exigeants et sortir du cliché
associés aux gens quelque chose de plus
raffiné un texte enjeu dans par le mythe
où on parle de mon possible de thann
asie ont des thèmes un peu quoi pointu
et dramatique mais qui font rien pour
l'association et drôle
le marché du théâtre d'été a énormément
changé au cours des dernières années des
années 80 85 qu'il y avait une centaine
de théâtre d'été
aujourd'hui si un novice et bout le
producteur de spectacles jean bernard
hébert assister aux premières loges à
cette évolution
j'ai vu le milieu se transforme en moins
quatre fois au cours des 35 dernières
années
l'humour a pris beaucoup de place aussi
les festivals et fêtes et festivals ont
plus beaucoup d'ampleur aussi mais il va
toujours y avoir un public de voir du
beau et du bon théâtre en été
une évolution qui s'explique entre
autres par une transformation des
rythmes de production télévisuelle
vous savez avant terme était une
tradition c'est que quand les téléromans
terminé dans les années 50-60 même 70
y'a pas d'enregistrement l'été donc
évidemment les comédiens tomber sans
revenu donc le théâtre d'été été pendant
des années une source de revenus
importante pour les comédiens
et on assiste également une montée en
popularité des spectacles musicaux à
grand déploiement tels que mamma mia ou
amsterdam le spectacle musical inspiré
de la vie de jacques brel que ça soit
par un théâtre musical que ce soit par
une comédie je pense que les cotes des
gens que ça soit l'été ou une autre
saison et ben helli la main il ya une
sensibilité en fait tilt et qui se
continue et chemin que les gens les
créateurs sont plus à l'écouté de sang
même si les goûts évoluent tous
s'entendent pour dire que l'été le
public préfère le spectacle léger et
rafraîchissant et le théâtre d'été reste
une forme d'art populaire qui voyagent
en région à la rencontre des spectateurs
qui souhaitent s'initier au théâtre en
passant de bons moments ici des biens
alexandre chartier radio canada montréal